unos 300 bomberos pasaron la noche
luchando contra un enorme y según las
autoridades el peor incendio forestal en
el sureste de españa el fuego comenzó
cuando un rayo cayó el sábado por la
noche en el área del vall d'ebo en la
provincia de alicante desde entonces las
llamas se extendieron rápidamente
arrasando casi diez mil hectáreas en una
zona de difícil acceso y obligando a la
evacuación de más de mil personas
creo que es mejor tener cuidado porque
todo está tan seco que solo necesitas
una chispa y todo comenzará eso lo
entiendo muy bien aguanten perfectamente
los rascacielos de madrid conocidos como
las cuatro torres se cubrieron de humo
proveniente de un incendio forestal en
el centro de portugal a unos 400
kilómetros de distancia los residentes
de la capital española se quejaron del
fuerte olor increíble como como la
naturaleza puede llegar a manifestarse
en tantas partes porque pues si
solamente estaban portugal rendía uno
que allá es el problema y mira como
como un problema que paga ya no sé qué
tan grande haya sido en 100 imprimirá el
hecho de que llegue a estar acá y de
hecho todo está así no todo está nublado
no sé son los edificios de lejos no se
ve
el incendio comenzó el 6 de agosto y fue
extinguido en gran medida el domingo
pero se reavivó este lunes y provocó la
evacuación de varias zonas en portugal
los incendios forestales han arrasado
unas 85 mil hectáreas hay casi 1% del
país el porcentaje más alto de la unión
europea si bien la temporada alta de
incendios aún no ha terminado el balance
provisional aumenta en la unión europea
con más de 660.000 hectáreas quemadas
desde enero estableciendo un récord en
esta etapa del año